what i want to introduce you to in this
video is the notion of a proportional
relationship
and a proportional relationship between
two variables is just a relationship
where the ratio between the two
variables is always going to be the same
thing so let's look at an example of
that
so let's just say that we want to think
about the relationship between x and y
and let's say that when x is 1
y is 3
and then when x is 2
y is 6
and when x is 9
y is 27
now this is a proportional relationship
why is that because the ratio between y
and x is always the same thing and
actually the ratio between y and x or
you could say the ratio between x and y
is always the same thing so for example
if we say the ratio y over x this is
always equal to it could be 3 over 1
which is just 3 it could be 6 over 2
which is also just 3 it could be 27
over 9 which is also just 3. so we see
that y over x
y over x is always going to be equal to
3 or at least in this table right over
here and so at least based on the data
points we've just seen so based on this
it looks like that we have a
proportional relationship between y and
x so this one right over here is
proportional
so given that's what's an example of
relationships that are not proportional
well those are fairly easy to construct
so let me let's say we had
i'll do it with two different variables
so let's say we have
a
and b
a and b and let's say when a is one b is
three
and when a is 2
b is 6
and when a is 10
b is 35.
so here you might say oh look look what
you know when a is 1 b is 3 so the ratio
between for the ratio b to a you could
say b to a
it's you could say well it's when when b
is three a is one or when a is one b is
three so three to one and that's also
the case when b is six a is two or when
a is two b is six so it's six to two so
these ratios seem to be the same they're
both three but then all of a sudden the
ratio is different right over here this
is not equal to thirty-five over ten
this is not equal to thirty-five over
10. so this is not a proportional
relationship in order to be proportional
the ratio between the two variables
always has to be the same
so this right over here this is not
not
proportional
not proportional so the key in
identifying a proportional relationship
is look at the different values that the
variables take on when one variable is
one value and then what does the other
variable become and then take the ratio
between them here we took the ratio y to
x and you see y to x or y divided by x
the ratio of y to x is always going to
be the same here so this is proportional
and you could actually go on the other
way you could have said well what's the
ratio of x to y
x to y
well over here would be 1 to 3
1 to 3 which is the same thing as 2 to 6
which is the same thing as 9 to 27
9 to 27 when you take this ratio between
if you say the ratio of x to y instead
of y to x you see that it's always
one-third but any way you look at it the
ratio between these two variables if you
say y to x it's always going to be three
or x to y is always going to be
one-third so this is proportional while
this one is not